مؤتمر ابل السنوي نقدر نلخصه فيه النظاره
اللي صارت حديث الناس وحسستنا انه نحن
انتقلنا للمستقبل فالنظاره اللي كنا
بنشوفها في الافلام وشفنا الشيب يشبهها في
احدى حلقات مسلسل الخيال العلمي اللي كسر
الدنيا على نتفليكس من سنوات واللي كنا
بنفكر انه لو حنشوفها حقيقه يعني مو الان
هذه النظاره ابل خلتها حقيقه والان كمان
كشفت خلال مؤتمرها السنوي في كاليفورنيا
عن نظاره فيجن برو بتجمع بين الواقع
الافتراضي والحقيقه النظاره قيل انها
حائزه على 5000 براءه اختراع وتقدر تلبسها
وتتحكم من خلالها بكل شيء حوالينك شاشات
مكالمات كمبيوتر وغيرها من خلال الاوامر
الصوتيه وحركه العين واليد وحتكون متاحه
للبيع السنه القادمه في الولايات المتحده
وطبعا اعلان زي هذا وكما هو بسهم ابل اللي
ارتفع وسجل رقم قياسي جديد للمره الاولى
من 17 شهر النظاره الكثار حتى مو فاهمين
بالضبط بالضبط يعني ايش فايدتها كان فيها
جانب اخر صادم للناس
مميزاتها فالسعر عمل بلبله ليه لانها
ببساطه بثلاثه الاف وخمسميه دولار وردت
فعلا حاضرين في المؤتمر لحظه الاعلان عن
سعرها عكست لحد كبير رده الفعل على هذا
الموضوع لاحقا على المنصات
النظاره فعليا عامله ضجه يعني مو بس بعالم
التكنولوجيا والاعمال والاسهم فعلى
المنصات الناس حول العالم شغلها الشاغل
الساعات الماضيه نظارات ابل وبصراحه
النظاره تحولت لماده دسمه للميمز والنكت
ان كان بسبب سعرها ولا العالم كيف حيصير
بسببها ولا التعليقات على مارك زاكربيرج
فالناس اعتبرت انه يعني ابل سبقت متى في
عالم النظارات
لايك
[تصفيق]
لو حطينا المزح بالضحك على جنب نظاره ابل
فعليا عامله انقسام بين الناس والاراء
حولها متضاربه جدا في عاشقي التكنولوجيا
اللي مبهورين ومبسوطين فيها جدا وشايفينها
الثوره في هذا العالم وفي المعترضين وهذول
منهم اللي شايفينوا هذا تطور تكنولوجي
كبير والعالم لسه مو مستعد له وفي طبعا
اللي شايف السعر فلكي معانا من سانهزي في
كاليفورنيا الصانع المحتوى التقني فيصل
السيف اهلا فيك معانا يا فيصل اول شيء كيف
الجو عندك
مساكم الله بالخير
الجو جميل الله يسعدكم يا رب مساك الله
بالخير متابعيني جميل والامور حلوه جميل
جدا انت من المبهورين كمان بموضوع النظاره
ولا شايف انه لا
جميل جدا الحين تكلمنا على السعر فهو
بالفعل السعر حق المطورين اللي متاح له
النظارات المرحله الاولى من اين
ظهر بتقنيه جديده من شركتكم بسعر مره
مرتفع
بهذا السعر المرتفع وحتى ترى متى لها
مرتفع هذا الجانب نعم من المستخدمين دائما
في اي مؤتمر لابل دائما يشوفوا السعر على
اساس انه كيف اشتري ساعه
والكلام ده كله الكل يصير ابيع كليه ابيع
مدري ايش اوكي بس
جدا كثيره ولكن تكلم على فئه جديده حتى
تطبيقات متوقع نفس المنصه النظاره
تطبيقاتها
زي باقي النظارات حتى البرامج التطبيقات
غاليه يعني هذه
يعني خلينا نقول صريحين اللي حيشتروها
المهوسين بالتكنولوجيا واللي حابين
يتفشخروا
اين نقدر نقول اوكي هذا هذا
مجموعه معينه اللي ما يستخدموها بسوروا
فيها اوكي بس طيب بس مين هي معموله لمين
يعني
الفئه هذه الاولى لو تلاحظوا انه اسمها
حتى الجوالات وفي منها فحيكون في نسخه
مخففه حسب التوقعاتي حتكون السنه الجايه
تطرح فالحين المطورين واصحاب الاعمال
البزنس يقدروا يستفيدوا منها بانهم
يتبنوها ويحاولوا يطوروا فيها تطبيقات
واشياء منظوميه منها يجيبوا ربح ضخم مجنون
فوق ما تتصوروا بان اتيحت المنصه من ابل
لاول مره في تاريخه منصه تتاح فرص كثيره
للاعمال تطرحه للافراد المطورين ابدا مو
من المستخدمين وابدا مول الفشخره واصلا
شكل الواحد حيكون غريب شوي فيها طيب يعني
نحن الناس العاديين اللي اول شيء بندفع
3,500 وما احنا ولا مطورين ما نشتري الان
يعني
لا تشتروا الحين وانت سويتيني انا فئه
المعاديه لان انا بشتري
[ضحك]
يتكلموا عنها انه لما تلبسها حتقدر انك
مثلا تكون بتصور مثلا مناسبه انت عايشها
والكلام ده كله فبيقولوا لك انه ابل
بزياده تبغانا كمان يعني احنا اولادي صرنا
ما بنعيش حياتنا لانه بنصور بالتليفون
الان حتى بالنظاره حنمشي يعني في حياتنا
هل هذا المستقبل اللي بنطلع له جميل جميل
جدا سؤالك لانه انا من واجه من منظور تقني
الامر اللي شرحوه وقالوا انه تصوير ثلاثي
الابعاد من خلال النظاره بالنسبه للتقنيه
غير مقبول هذا صعبه جدا صعبه تقنيا انك
تصور ثلاثي الابعاد تقدر تصور بابعاد تقدر
تصور بنموذج محدد وايضا انهم احنا معليش
يعني انت تقعد في البيت لحالك او مع
عائلتك لابس نظاره قاعده تصور فيهم
الموضوع مو طبيعي وامر عدم وجود الحس
الطبيعي في التقنيات المل بوسه يخلي الناس
تنفر عنها مش تقرب منها لو انتوا النظاره
هذه كانت بشكل هذه النظاره وفيها الكاميرا
مدمجه وشويه اشياء قد تكون اقرب للناس بس
كونها كبيره هذا مجال جديد وما اظن الناس
بيقعدوا يمشوا فيها يقعدوا يصوروا اصلا
لما اقعد اختبر النظارات في المكتب
[موسيقى]
بنشكرك على هذا الموضوع وان شاء الله تقضي
ايام حلوه في كاليفورنيا وترجع بالسلامه
واذا حتجرب النظاره صور لنا طبعا اكيد
حتصور صور لنا التجربه كيف الكلام هذا كله
طيب كان معنا
صانع المحتوى التقاليد فيصل الصيف شكرا لك